hey 42 here it's been almost 50 years
since the Illuminati paid NASA two
million dollars to pay Stanley Kubrick 1
million dollars to fake the moon
landings in the Roswell carpark in order
to ensure the Russians gave up and
didn't set up an invaluable cheese
Factory on the moon jokes aside who even
cares about the moon
what's it ever done for us it's just a
big lump of rock that makes dogs bark
occasionally and gets in the way of the
Sun right well how much influence does
the moon actually have on our planet
would life without it be much different
let's find out the first thing to deal
with is how we came to have a moon in
the first place now since we haven't
kept any of the receipts we don't have a
definite answer it's possible that the
earth and moon both just formed
simultaneously from the same cluster of
space junk about 4.5 billion years ago
but this doesn't explain why the moon
contains so little metal compared to
earth if both objects came from the same
junk they were both consist of the same
stuff another idea is that it was the
matter that was flung out of the Earth's
crust by the force of the spinning
motion that formed the moon but we need
to have been whizzing around as an
incredible rate and it would have made
the dinosaurs feel a bit unwell or it
could have been a wandering object
drifting through the galaxy but then we
would have needed a much much bigger
atmosphere in order to slow it down
sufficiently to capture it so the most
likely theory is that a planet about the
same size of Mars which we've named fear
crashed into us and while some of the
massiveness of a planet who is added to
earth the debris from this impact stayed
in orbit around us and slowly drew
together over about a year to form the
moon this happened about 50 million
years after the solar system formed and
earth was probably still partly molten
at this point this impact would have
liquefied the entire surface so when it
resettled after about a day or so there
would have been no impact crater
remaining it also explains the
difference in metal levels between the
moon and Earth since the metal core of
fear would have been drawn into
own core thanks to its greater mouths
whilst the lighter nonmetal parts would
have stayed in orbit and gone on to
become the moon so fear probably
increased our spin rate but if the moon
hadn't stayed around then we would have
been stuck with days just six or eight
hours long meaning your average cricket
match would take about a month the moon
slows us down by tidal friction every
time it drags the oceans a few meters of
the beach not only does it spoil our Sun
castles but the friction between the
water and the seafloor shaves a tag tiny
fraction of the year this frictional
energy is transferred to the moon
because it creates a tidal bulge in the
oceans which runs slightly ahead of the
moon you I can get on behind it this
extra kick makes the moon accelerate
whilst it slows us down we shave off a
few milliseconds each year so in about 4
million years the leap year will become
unnecessary as for the moon it moves
away by three or more centimetres
annually however the tides play a far
more important role in just creating
some friction life evolved in the oceans
given that is much easier to survive
around the warm jet of water than it is
on a tiny bit of crusted over lava rock
but as you can see from looking around
you we managed to escape the oceans and
get on with the messy business of living
all over Earth's dry bits sort of like
Expo the tides played two important
roles in this firstly when life was
forming billions of years ago the moon
was much closer to us about half the
distance it is now
so which gravitational pull would have
been four times greater making the tide
much bigger molecular biologist Richard
lave says that this would have created
large low tide areas which were very
salty
since the Sun would evaporate the water
producing an environments that proto
nucleic acid fragments would have needed
to form into molecular strands in other
words large salty dry bits along the
coastline led to more advanced organisms
secondly after life had done a bit of
mating and evolving in the ocean any
aquatic organisms living on the
shoreline would often find itself
stranded out of the war
when the moon dragged the sea away from
it so it was either sink or swim well
the opposite I guess expects eight or
brief sure life had to adapt to its no
fifty-fifty life in and out of water and
soon there were organisms that could
manage without the ocean entirely we'd
still have tides without the moon thanks
to the pull of the Sun but they'd be
well under half of what they are now
it's actually the combined pull of the
Sun and Moon that creates the spring
tides so without the moon creating
exceptionally strong tides it's unlikely
that evolution would have happens this
fast and we probably wouldn't be here
today this Sun and Moon team is also
important for night vision the moon may
only be one in four hundred thousand
times as bright as a Sun but that tiny
amount of light that it does reflect is
itself thousands and thousands of times
stronger than anything else in the sky
if you go out into the countryside on a
moonless night you'll realize just how
little you can see without that giant
lunar reflection you'll also probably
get eaten by bears because the
countryside is just awful and full of
bears and snakes so with much darker
night it's likely that many nocturnal
creatures would have evolved much
differently like relying on other senses
such as hearing that's not to say that
there would be no night vision though
some species such as the elephant hawk
moth are so well adapted to seeing in
darkness that they can see color for
humans when it's less than half
moonlight the cones in our eyes don't
have enough photons to work with so we
only use the rods which can't sense any
color and we only see black and white
without the moon's assistance we
probably would have been very vulnerable
once the Sun went down the final major
impact that the moon has had on us is
the tilt of Earth's axis Mars currently
has a tilt similar to ours about 24
degrees from the Sun but unlike ours
Mars axis can vary a great deal
sometimes going down to 15 and up to 35
degrees at times
earth would do the same if it weren't
for the stabilizing effect of the moon
this change in tilt would be an
ecological nightmare since it would
wildly vary the seasons imagine having
three years of continuous winter oh that
actually sounds like normal life in the
north of England - all the White Walkers
of course thanks for the view subscribe
for more thoughty2 for this lake bed is
littered with hundreds of hundreds of
skeletal human remains then you could be
an extraordinarily intelligent person
possibly even genius level